Well, good morning church.
Aren't you glad our new heaters are working so well today?
Amen. Right. What a ride The last few days have been
earthquakes and bitter cold
and, uh, finding out I have a torn meniscus.
So it's been a great week.
Uh, gonna get it, uh, cleaned up a week from tomorrow,
so thank you for praying for that.
Also, you may have noticed, uh, it's hard not
to if you were in the lobby, the big number 60 out there,
uh, it is like 10 feet tall,
but uh, maybe some new logos around as well.
Why do we have those going on?
Well, because this year is our 60th anniversary as a church,
uh, we are celebrating
that over the next few months we're gonna highlight
what God has done over the years
as we're standing here on the shoulders
or sitting here on the shoulders of
so many who've gone before us.
And we're just gonna highlight that, uh, culminating in a,
a big celebration in late April.
As we honor what God's done today though,
we're gonna continue in our new first things
first sermon series.
We're studying the essential doctrines
of the Christian faith.
What makes us distinctly Christian?
Uh, as I shared last week, you saw it in the video again,
we, we can't focus on second and third tier matters.
First. We can't put the pebbles in the sand in the jar first
because then the big rocks won't fit.
We can't get them appropriately as they need to be in there.
And so we gotta put the primary things in first,
the first things in first, and then those less important
or or unclear doctrines can fit
around those in a healthy way.
And tho there's gonna be seven of these.
There's probably more you could find, but,
but there's seven we're gonna look at
that are big rocks essentials
to our faith over the next few weeks.
So our first big rock last Sunday,
it's already in the jar now you can see it was the doctrine
of revelation that God has revealed himself
to us in nature through his word
and even by coming in Jesus Christ.
And so our second big rock as we get to today is
what God has told us about himself.
And so we'll put the second rock in here.
It is the attributes of God.
What has God told us about himself? What God is, who God is.
That's what we're looking at today, the things
that are true about his nature, his essence, plus
what is true about his person.
We're gonna see a lot of those today.
Now, it is only going to be a glimpse of that today.
This is a massive doctrine just to,
we'll see how big God is.
So think about how big this belief is.
And so we're just gonna look at a glimpse of it.
We're gonna start in Acts 17 today.
So grab your copy of God's Word.
Turn with me to Acts chapter 17.
It's in the New Testament that will be in Acts 17 for that.
Now, I said it last week
that many religions teak teach things about their gods,
many of which may be similar to things we say about God.
And so it's important for us to distinguish
what we mean when we say God.
For example, many people would believe
that we worship the same God that Muslims worship.
We don't. It's not true.
You're gonna see things today that are only true of the God,
of the universe.
Very different than other gods out there.
But the difficulty of doing this, of really
any theological study, it's what's been said
before, that all of our attempts to define God
only serve to diminish God
because he's so much higher than,
than even our words can explain
and understand in our, our little brains.
Like he's so, so we have to try, right?
We, we can't not have beliefs, right?
But we just have to realize these things are going
to diminish in a way what God really is,
who God really is.
So we have to have beliefs about proper beliefs about God
because if we don't have proper beliefs about God, then,
then all of us are theologians.
All of us are thinking about God in some way.
So either we have right beliefs
or we're making up our own stuff about who God is, who we,
who we want him to be maybe.
And that becomes who we conceive God to be.
But that is just what you'll see in Acts 17
and imagining something.
And that's called idolatry. It's not where we want to be.
And so to get proper beliefs about God, we study his word,
his special revelation, what he's told us about himself,
that's where we find out about him.
But here's another caution.
We cannot just study the Bible to be informed about God.
We must study the Bible to be transformed by God.
Calvin said it to know God is to be changed by God.
That's the whole point of this.
What true theology does is it brings our minds to a place
where we understand more about who this God really is.
It should only lead us to worship him more.
That's what this whole series is about.
And so as we turn to Acts 17, lemme set the context
for you as we get there.
The Apostle Paul was on one
of his missionary journeys throughout the Mediterranean.
Here he was in Athens, Greece.
You can still go to some of these same places.
Even today, Athens was full of people trying to figure out
who and what God is.
There were spiritual, religious,
but they didn't know the truth of God's special revelation
to point them to salvation.
They had a sense of God,
they could see God in some sense in nature,
but they, they didn't know who he was.
And so they were trying to figure it out. Enter Paul.
He saw idols everywhere.
So he began preaching about Jesus and the resurrection
and boldly doing that.
And so naturally these, these inquisitive people,
religious people would ask for more information.
So here's how Paul responded.
He preached one of the most powerful evangelistic
sermons you will ever hear.
And it's here in Acts 17, starting in verse 22.
Just gonna see the sermon that he preached here.
Acts 17, starting in 22 down through 31.
So Paul standing in the midst of the Areopagus, this is
where they would debate ideas and things like that.
He said, this men of Athens, I perceive
that in every way you are very religious.
For as I passed along
and observed the objects of your worship,
I found also an altar with this inscription
to the unknown God.
Like they were just trying to cover their bases,
basically Make sure we get at all of 'em, right?
What therefore you worship as unknown.
This I proclaim to you that God who made the world
and everything in it being Lord of heaven
and earth does not live in temples made by man,
nor is he served by human hands
as though he needed anything.
Since he himself gives to all mankind life
and breath and everything.
And he made from one man every nation of mankind
to live on all the face of the earth,
having determined allotted periods
and the boundaries of their dwelling place
that they should seek God
and perhaps feel their way toward him and find him.
Yet he's actually not far from each one of us.
For in Him we live and move and have our being.
As some of even your own poets have said,
for we are indeed his offspring.
Well being then God's offspring, we ought not to think
that the divine being is like gold or silver or stone.
An image formed by the art and imagination of man.
The times of ignorance got overlooked.
But now he commands all people everywhere to repent
because he's fixed a day on which he will judge the world in
righteousness by a man whom he has appointed in all of this.
He's given assurance to all by raising him from the dead.
God, thank you for this powerful passage
where Paul gets to describe
in limited form even who you are.
So show us today who we need to see you to be
the truth of who you are.
Open our eyes to see it.
Open our hearts to understand it
and our minds to understand it a little bit more.
So that we would live as you want us
to live a little bit more every day.
Thank you God. Give us eyes today in Jesus' name. Amen.
Now when we talk about the attributes of God,
we don't mean like component parts of God,
like water is components of hydrogen
and oxygen mixed together and this makes water.
No, no. When we talk about the attributes of God,
we're talking about how each one of these
describes his total being.
So he is all of these things in all ways yet
because we again are limited, we've said a lot today
because we're limited by our humanity.
We have to talk about his attributes separately.
And so scholars have often broken down God's attributes
into two categories.
I'm gonna follow uh,
Gerald bra pretty closely today in how he structured this.
First there are God's essential attributes.
So two categories. First, his essential attributes.
These are the things that are essential to his being.
They're at the core of how God works, right?
Essential. These are also the things of God that we would
call incommunicable.
It's a really fun word to say, by the way.
It just sounds like you're babbling incommunicable, right?
Spills out of your mouth, right? Incommunicable.
So anyway, you can surprise your
friends later with that one.
But meaning that that word means
that they don't translate from him to us.
They're not shared.
They are only true of the God of the universe.
They're not true of us in any way.
They're only true of him fully.
So there's essential who he is in that kind of what he is.
But there are also what we call God's relational attributes.
So we have essential and relational.
These are the things that describe how he relates to us
and and these are really things that we can share as well.
That's why we mean these are communicable.
They were incommunicable before and essential, but,
but these relational ones are able to be shared.
But we have to remember this though as we say that
God is these things in an absolute sense.
He is perfectly all of these relational attributes, even
where we, even though we can express them in some way,
are still going to be limited in the way
we can express them.
God is perfect in everything He is.
We will show some of these but not perfectly.
So I know this is difficult already.
We're getting into it pretty quickly. So let's use act 17.
Use this as a way to kind of see these essential
and relational attributes in a limited form.
So first we're gonna look at some
of God's essential attributes.
What are some examples we can find even here?
Now, the three we're gonna look at today,
we call these the Omnis.
Not just a chain of nice hotels.
But all you see here is
what God is like.
This is his nature.
Again, we're not saying these are the only three,
not comprehensive, but even just these three will see,
will emphasize how different God is than us.
His otherness. You might say,
here's the first one, omnipotence.
Put it on the screen so you can see it.
Write it down omnipotence.
Now what does that prefix omni actually mean? It means all.
And so you see the word all
and then do you see the word potent there?
Potent. Potent. It means powerful.
Like that plugin, air fresh, nurture your house.
It is potent, right? There's, there's a power there, right?
So when we say omnipotence, what we mean is
that God is all powerful.
It means he can do anything and everything.
You see that here in Paul's description of God,
in in verses 24
and 25, the God who made the world
and everything in it being Lord of heaven
and earth does not live in temples made by man.
Nor is he served by human hands
as though he needed anything.
Since he himself gives to all mankind life and breath
and everything, right?
So you see it here, God is described
as the creator of everything.
He's the Lord of heaven and earth.
That means he created it all and he's sovereign over it all.
That by definition means he's all powerful.
To give life, you have to have life in yourself.
All powerful.
But it also means that God does not need to be fed or
provided for like their gods did in Athens.
In fact, there's nothing we can ever provide for God
because he never hungers.
He never thirsts. He never sleeps.
He he never suffers and need to be cared for.
He never needs anything. He's all powerful.
He's self-sustaining, doesn't need any outside force.
He's never changing.
He is the same yesterday, today and forever.
He's without beginning. He's uncreated, he's eternal.
He's immortal, he's infinite.
He actually gives us all that we need.
That all means he's all powerful.
He's omni
potent, all powerful.
Here's the second one.
We could talk a lot more about that one of course,
but there's a second here.
Omnipresence, omni
again all and then the word presence, location.
This word means he is all present.
God is present every point of space with his whole being.
He is everywhere you see it here, look again verses 26
through 28, he made from one man every nation of mankind
to live on all the face of the earth.
There's a little more of the creative power having
determined allotted periods.
That means the time in which they live
and boundaries in their dwelling place means he's
sovereign over where we live.
And when that they should seek God,
perhaps feel their way toward him and find him.
Yet he's actually not that far from us.
So you see this idea that he, the God of the universe
is fully present in every place.
He's scattered humanity all over the world
and yet he is near to everyone.
So he has to be omnipresent in order to be near
to everyone all over the world.
He's fully present in every place.
Now, those pagan gods, the ones in Athens,
they were local deities
and they were, they were just like for their little region
or for their group of people.
But God is different.
In fact, I love how Psalm 1 39 describes it so well.
David says, where shall I go from your spirit?
God, where shall I flee from your presence?
If I ascend to heaven, you are there.
If I make my bed in Shol the place
of the dead, you are there.
If I take the wings of the morning
and dwell in the uttermost parts of the sea,
even there your hand shall lead me
and your right hand shall hold me.
How is it possible though for God to be everywhere?
Because in his essence, right, this is, this is the things
that are not communicable to us.
In his essence, God is spirit. He's invisible.
He's infinite. So he can be everywhere.
Now. Now let's think about that for a second
because if God is everywhere,
that means he is everywhere, right?
And that can be bad news to us
because that means there's nothing we can hide from God.
But listen, it should also be good news for us
because you saw what David said in Psalm 1 39,
wherever we go, God is there with us.
Like that's good news too, right?
It should be a, a sense of fear
and some, some worry about that
because God is seeing everything he's there in it.
But it should also be for those who are his good news.
Because wherever you go, he's there.
Wherever he leads you, he's there.
Like even when we experienced
what we've experienced the last couple days
where things literally feel shaken
and it feels like life is shaking so badly that you can't
stand, listen to this Psalm 46,
God is our refuge
and strength a very present
help in trouble.
Therefore, because he's present,
we will not fear though the earth gives way.
Man, it felt like that.
Saturday morning we will not fear though
the earth gives way though the mountains be moved into the
heart of the sea, though its waters roar
and foam, though its mountains tremble at its swelling.
Like even when the chaos of everything is crushing us,
it seems we will not fear.
Notice why? Because God, our refuge,
our strength is very near.
He's present, he's there. He's keeping you safe.
Now there's, there's one that's really closely linked to
that, that he's all present.
It's that he's, this is the third one. He is omniscient.
Omniscience is our third omni today.
Now you see the word science there, right?
Means knowledge, omni knowledge.
God is all knowing.
He's all powerful. He's all present, he's all knowing.
You see that here in Acts 17 where at the end of
that passage I read it says that God knows the heart
of every person and he will judge the world
in righteousness.
How does he know our hearts? Because he knows everything.
He knows everything that could ever be known.
He also knows the past and he knows the future.
He has an advantage because he's outside of time.
He's timeless. Yet God works
inside within time.
'cause notice it says he has fixed a day, right?
That's time-based He, he's working within the timeline
of history that he created.
He designed, he's outside of it, but he's working within it.
Now, this attribute of God may be more difficult
to grasp than all the others.
They're all interconnected. Yes, they work together.
But this one brings up the most questions.
Now let me be clear. What we don't believe first is
that God is up in heaven merely responding
to things happening down here that's called open theism.
That God doesn't really know what's coming
and so he's just kind of like trying
to catch up in some ways
and making it happen as it's happening.
No, God knows all past, present, future,
he is in control.
But the most common question still sits out there,
okay, if if God knows everything, if God plans,
what about free will?
I mean are, are we just robots then
Like Will will God truly fulfill his promises to us?
I mean we don't really know for sure how
and those are common that all of us, including myself,
we wrestle with,
well one of our favorite Bible characters is named Job.
Job asked questions like that
based on his life and his experiences.
It's in the Old Testament,
but I want you to listen to how God responded to Job.
It says Job chapter 38, this is God speaking
to Job says, where were you when I laid
the foundation of the earth?
Tell me if you have understanding
who determined its measurements, surely you know
or who stretched the line upon it, measured it on
what were its basis sunk its foundations
or who laid its cornerstone?
Have you commanded the mourning since your days began
and caused the dawn to know its place?
Have you entered into the springs of the sea
or walked in the recesses of the deep?
Have the gates of death been revealed to you
or have you seen the gates of deep darkness?
Have you comprehended the expanse of the earth?
Declare if you know all this,
what was God saying to Job?
He's saying, I'm God, you're not.
And he wasn't saying it in like a
sarcastic mean kind of way.
He's just reminding Job, Hey,
I understand this way more than you ever will.
You are limited and Job.
Finally at the course of the the book, he finally realizes
that we need to realize this same thing
that God has God a warn out.
There's gonna be things we don't understand yet.
Hear me in this. It's okay to wrestle
with those questions.
People have done that for thousands of years trying
to figure out how this all works out,
that God is in control and how does this work?
Yes. However, we must take those questions to him
like we need to ask those questions from a posture of faith
where we trust God is actually bigger
that he actually does know
and though I might not be able to conceive, he actually does
know what he's doing.
In fact, I love Richard Baxter's perspective on all this.
He's looking at these essential attributes of who God is
and what our response should be.
This is what he wrote from this greatness
and immensity of God.
Your soul must reverently pause all its busy,
bold inquiries and know that God is to us
and to every creature incomprehensible.
If you could fathom or measure him
and know his greatness by a comprehensive knowledge,
he were not God.
A creature can comprehend nothing but a creature.
You may know God but not comprehend him.
Listen to this part. The ocean is not the ocean if you can
hold it in a spoon.
See, that's the idea here. Our God is like no other church.
His nature is utterly different
and that should cause us to worship.
It should be good news to us that he is this.
But thankfully God also has
what we call relational attributes.
Relational attributes.
This is not just what God is, all powerful, all present,
all knowing He is that this is who God is.
Essential describes his nature,
relational describes his person, how he relates to us,
and again, God is fully these things in himself
and in a sense though he also shares them with us.
They're communicable.
As I said earlier, since we're in his image,
he can share some of these things with us
and so let's look at three of these.
The first and most fundamental is his holiness
relational attribute.
Number one, his holiness.
It's how God revealed himself to Moses, to Isaiah,
I am the holy one.
He says, in fact, later he repeats
and we see in a New Testament be holy because I am holy.
God says, but what is holiness? We need to answer.
What does it mean to be holy?
Well, at its root is separation.
It's difference from other things.
Now, God certainly is that, especially in contrast to us.
We just saw it, right? He is different,
completely different from his creatures worthy of worship
above anything else that was clear in Acts 17, it's all over
that we saw it clearly.
He's also though not just separated from creatures,
he's separated from sin.
He says, we are to be separated from sin as well,
to be different, to conform our lives to him.
That's what Romans 12, two says, don't be conformed
to this world but be transformed by the renewal
of your mind, that by testing you may discern
what is the will of God.
What is good and acceptable and perfect. That's holiness.
Is that your more aligned your your connected
and set apart in the way that
God is Yet again, yes, God calls us
to holiness, but we are unable to be truly
or completely like our Lord in that like Jesus was
his entire life separate.
It's because of our sin,
but that's where we saw in Romans 12.
That's where the grace of God powerfully transforms
us to do that more, to be
separating ourselves from the world,
separating ourselves from our flesh.
That's what God does to communicate that
to us is he makes us wholly
as we separate more, which that leads us
to the second relational attribute we'll look at today is
this idea of righteousness.
God is holy, God is righteous.
The idea here is that God always does what is right
even though we might not understand it,
even though we might not agree with it.
God always does what is right.
He always is just because he's the creator.
He sets the standard for what is right
and what is wrong for how justice is measured out.
The creator has that right to do that,
and so we have to be really careful to sit in judgment over
what we perceive God to be doing
and think that's not right God,
because he always is even in his wrath
towards sin.
It's not anger,
it's not nastiness.
Wrath is an expression of his righteousness.
That disobedience to his will comes at a price.
It's an expression of righteousness
and so how that plays out for us then is it,
it's communicated to us it's slightly different than
holiness against separation from the world.
Righteousness is how we live in the world
that we begin doing
what is right since we now check this out.
God does it right since we are now holy in him.
We're made the righteousness of God in Christ.
Second Corinthians five says,
then we can now act rightly more in this
world like Jesus did.
Right? Jesus was fully set apart,
yet lived it out in a righteous right kind of way.
That's what God does for us.
Sets us apart, makes us holy, so we live it out today.
Here's the third one, goodness, holiness,
righteousness, goodness.
All three of these are very closely related,
but goodness means that God is the final standard of good
and all that he does is worthy of approval.
It's what good means. Now, this is true in a physical sense.
You look back to creation.
Genesis one and two, when God looked at
what he did every day, he stood back
and he said, that's good.
It is good. Like when I grill a steak
and it looks like it does on the plate,
I say, that is good, right?
So that's this similar kind of idea.
God stepped back and he said, that is worthy of approval.
All that I did on day 1, 2, 3, I created it. I did it.
It's good, but that's also true in a moral sense
that everything God does is worthy of approval.
Then when we do the same things he says are good,
we are worthy of approval in that as well.
Yet here's, here's where this one trips us up.
There's a lot of questions that come from this.
If all that God does is worthy of approval,
how could it be good for concentration camps,
tragic deaths, cancer war?
How does that classify as good?
Well, we have to remember sometimes we suffer
because of our own sin.
Yes, but often we suffer just
because we live in a fallen world
that our, that our suffering is not
because we did something at all
and so we, we have to realize that's part of it.
Yes, God does what is good,
but there's also this thing happening
in the world because of sin.
We're also all deserving of death
because of our sin, both physical and spiritual death.
And so this death is coming for all of us.
Jesus gives parable after parable, story
after story of things that that are like, yeah,
it looks tragic, but, but it's just part of the deal
because sin, we're all going to die
and it's not up to us when that happens.
Whether it happened early or late.
Yet, here's the beauty of the gospel is
that God intervened to save us from that
Through the suffering
and sacrifice of his son that everybody else were looked at.
So that's not good and Jesus dying on the cross was actually
the means to bring about good, so it was good.
And when we repent and believe in Jesus' life, death,
and resurrection in our place,
we are spared from the spiritual side of that death.
Maybe the physical side, but for sure the spiritual side
and we know Romans 8 28 says that all things for those
who love God, all things work together for good.
Here's the difference though.
We need to remember that that may not be here
'cause this life is not all there is, right?
That God is preparing us
for something else later, next life to come.
That may be the the good He is working it out to be.
Now, here's the thing I, I know
that all this stuff's pretty high level, like it's easy
to zone out, to check out, to think,
well, this stuff's not important.
This isn't a first thing really.
This is just for theologians to debate and all this stuff.
So why does this even matter?
Why is it, why is this a first thing, the attributes of God?
Why is this so important?
Like isn't it enough just to love Jesus?
I mean like that's why we're here.
Just love Jesus and we're moving on. We're good.
I'm gonna get to heaven. Like, uh, isn't that enough?
I want to, I wanna spend a few minutes here showing
how this study of God is so critical for us
because here's the reality of the world that we live in.
There's some spirituality and things like that,
but emphasizes the tangible, the physical,
and here's one way that you can make something of yourself.
You can change the world.
You can, you can rewrite your story.
You can do all of these kinds of things.
You can make it better here as Christians.
That can't be where we land, that it becomes material
only because we worship the God of the universe who sits
above and beyond this world who created this world,
which means he sees this world rightly the way it should.
Plus that means that we can have confidence while we're in
the world because of who he is.
I mean, just think about this. If God was limited like in
Athens to a time
or a place, then we could so easily be separated from him.
We would not be able to have a relationship with him
where he is always with us.
'cause we gotta go to that temple.
We gotta go to that location.
It's critical that we believe God is everywhere.
Think about this. If he was not outside of us,
if he's not other, if he's not outside of creation,
then he couldn't meet us in our suffering
and deliver us from it in Jesus.
'cause he'd be bound up by all of this.
He's gotta be out there. How about this?
If he could change,
then we would not have any assurance of our salvation
'cause what would, what would stop him from just deciding
the next day to say, I really don't wanna save you
all and wipe you out.
If he could change, we would not have any hope
that he's gonna fulfill his promises
because he, we don't know, but he doesn't.
He's the same. And finally, if he was not all powerful
man, then something could trip him up
and cause this whole thing to be derailed from, progressing
to the end that he designed it for.
He's got to be all of these things.
You see how important it is for us to know
what God says about his nature, about what he actually is,
that he's all present, all knowing, all powerful.
That gives us confidence today.
But then think about the relational attributes,
how we relate to him.
He's holy, he's righteous, he's good.
He wants us to be those as well that pleases him in it.
Yet the beauty here, this the beauty of what God has
said here, who he is, is that he provides
for us everything that he requires of us.
He's made us His holy children
planting His Holy Spirit in us, empowering us to live a life
that is righteous, which leads us to be good in our lives.
Where our lives align with what he wants.
That's what he's done and what he is doing in us.
So it's critical that we know he's holy,
that we know he is righteous.
You know he is good because that makes us
able to be that way.
Then plus, listen, if,
if we didn't truly know the nature of his love,
we'd have every reason to be afraid of him.
But because we know he is love,
we have no reason to be afraid.
He's a consuming fire to devour our sin,
but his nature is essentially love.
We can come without fear.
See, this is the beauty of studying his attributes.
We understand our relationship
with him much more clearly when we understand first
that he's different from us,
but then how he relates to us in spite of that,
how he brings us to himself as his children
because he loves us because of his grace.
Like should this not lead us to be stunned in worship,
should not lead us to be faithful in our living.
This is who our God is.